hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at the PERT defense so the
PERT defense starts out with pawn to e4
from white black responds pawn d6 white
moves pawn d4 and black develops Knight
to f6 attacking this pawn on e4 why
would really like to just go ahead and
bring his pawn to c4 but obviously since
we are attacking his pawn on e4 he's
going to develop his Knight to c3 and
from here we are going to bring our pawn
to g6 and this is the perc offense right
here and as you can see a couple things
you do want to notice one the perk
defense is the hyper modern opening
basically meaning that we are right now
not defending the center with our pawns
instead we are going to be fed
chattering our bishop to this g7 square
we have our knight nicely placed here on
f6 and we're going to try to attack and
defend the center with our minor pieces
and we're going to flank from the sides
here we're going to wait for our pawns
to push forward later on but we're first
going to defend and attack the center
with our minor pieces so keep that in
mind
another thing you'll see this is kind of
a passive opening in the beginning
obviously Black has many fighting
opportunities later on once he opens up
the board and counter-attacks later on
but black would really like early on an
aggressive game not to block his dark
squared bishop so this dark square
bishop can get into the board attack the
f2 pawn and put a lot of pressure on the
White King but with this move of pawn to
d6 we have blocked off this bishop and
this means two things one it means it
more than likely we're going to fan Chet
or Bishop to g7 there's no reason for us
to block off our dark square bishop if
we have no reason to bring our
Bishop to g7 and fianchetto also this
means that we have our LightSquared
Bishop this is easily developed for us
we can bring this to any of these
squares and a lot of times is black the
light square Bishop is one of your
weakest minor pieces because a lot of
time it gets blocked off early on and
the perk offense the light square bishop
does not get locked in so if you play a
lot of times with black and you see that
your light square bishop isn't getting a
lot of play you may want to try this out
because your light square bishop decks
are going to be very valuable in this
opening so today we're going to look at
the two main lines the Austrian attack
in the classical attack and we're going
to kind of look at what both sides
should be thinking when they're playing
so the first is the Austrian attack and
that is simply pawn to f4 and this is
the most aggressive opening that white
can play against black because you can
see all these pawns you're already
attacking the center and they're putting
a lot of pressure on black Black's gonna
have to play smart or white can easily
just march up the board and quickly
checkmate the King from here as is with
most of the moves that White's going to
move black simply going to respond
Bishop to g7 black would really like to
develop his Bishop to g7 then he would
just like the castle and then he would
like to start counter attacking so more
than likely all the moves are going to
see from white the most common ones
you're going to see you're f4 and Knight
to f3 but we're simply going to bring
our Bishop to g7 fianchetto our Bishop
and then wait to see where they move
from here the most common move in the
mainline you're just going to see Knight
to f3 developing their Knight to a very
good square f3 square behind this pawn
here and putting more pressure on the
center you can see they're putting a lot
of pressure on the center we're
eventually going to have to
counter-attack or we're going to be in a
lot of trouble from here like I said
before we're going to go ahead and
Castle King safety obviously number one
poverty especially in the Perk offense
since we're not attacking right now
we're on the defense so we if we're
going to play on the defense and they're
attacking us we want to make sure our
King is in safety
from here White has a few options one
thing you may see you may see them come
at you and already attack with the move
like pawn to e5 here simple we can
recapture with our pawn and they have to
choose if they choose to capture with
their pawn they're deep on that we can
simply come in with their with our queen
capture and when he captures with his
minor piece he's really losing a good
square with his knight on c3 more than
likely you're not going to see him
capture there instead you're gonna see
him capture with his pawn his F pawn and
then we can simply bring our Knight to
d5 which is a good square from now
obviously he can take it if he wants to
trade off pieces but you can see here
we're eventually going to have to
continue counter attacking White has a
very good setup he can bring his bishop
into the action he can Castle kingside
and he already has these two pawns in
the center with great great center
control he has his Knights nicely
developed so black is really going to
have to be cautious here but the main
line if we go back a few moves instead
of pawn to e5 the main line is actually
just Bishop to d3 and from here
we're just going to develop our knight
to c6 really want to develop our minor
pieces now since we're going to need to
put some pressure on the middle and then
from here more than likely you'll see
pawn or excuse me White Castle King side
obviously King safety and then from here
we're going to bring our Bishop into the
action Bishop to g4 we obviously want to
get this active and this does two things
one against our LightSquared Bishop
active painting this Knight down to the
Queen but also it gives our knight a
little outpost here on d7 obviously if
our Bishop is not developed yet and we
bring our Knight to d7 then our
LightSquared Bishop is going to be
blocked off and that's really not what
you want especially in the perk defense
and so it is kind of a passive defense
at the very beginning so this
development move on g4 is very good for
us because now if he wants to come in
let's say with the move of pawn to e5 we
have a few options one of those options
is just bring our knight back to d7
which is very good we're still applying
a lot of pressure and we're waiting for
white to make a move and then we can
counter-attack from here you might
simply see excuse me Bishop to e3 and
black has a lot of fighting moves in
this position obviously we've said
before Black has his pieces developed we
have King safety we can start to push up
the board if we want to we can get our
Queen involved so black has a very good
game here second variation we want to go
over is the classical defense and we'll
go ahead and get started once we move g7
now the classical attack is going to be
Knight to f3 and this is probably going
to be the most common that you're going
to see it's the main line in the perk
defense and what this does is it
develops its Knights to two great
squares Knight to f3 Knight to c3 and it
opens up both lines for the bishops the
bishops can roam all the way on this h6
to c1 and they can roam from the F
one to the a six square so very good
diagonals why has a lot of good
development move and he's going to have
a very good game and also he has very
good center control from here as we said
before we're simply going to bring our
Bishop to g7 obviously we're attacking
the center with our minor pieces from
the flank position on the side from here
you might see a couple different moves
from white you may see Bishop to e2 or
you also may see the simple move of pawn
to h3 keeping our Bishop block down
obviously white would not like our
Bishop to come to g4 because it's
developing our Bishop pinning down the
knight to the Queen White is going to
have to do something about this instead
you might see white simply move his pawn
to h3 taking away that great square post
from here we're simply just going to
Castle kingside if he doesn't though the
main line is for Bishop to come to e2
and then from here like before we're
going to go ahead and simply Castle
kingside from here why it's going to
Castle kingside and then now we can
bring our Bishop to g4 developing our
bishop again giving another outpost for
our knight to come to d7 which d7 is
actually a pretty good square for our
Knight we can still attack these two
dark squares which we are putting a lot
of pressure on the dark squares with our
dark square Bishop around g7 it frees
him up so he can attack and it the same
way gets this Knight out of harm's way
if Y decides to push down so
these are a few things that you want to
think about and the perk defense these
the most common that you'll see the
Austrian attack and the classical
defense just keep in mind that if you
are black you are going to want to
counter-attack and you are going to make
sure that you have King safety so if
they're playing aggressive if they're
playing the Austrian attack make sure
that you do counter attack in the game
or you may lose pretty quickly so hope
you guys enjoy this video hope you guys
learned a lot if you haven't already
please subscribe if you haven't checked
out the website got a lot of new fun
stuff on the bit on the website that's
WWE chess website calm thanks for
watching I'll see you guys next video